This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. It's summer time, so we felt we had to start our show with a scene from the iconic summer vacation movie. Where in the 1980s, the Griswals are packed into their station wagon. It's pouring rain. Everything has gone wrong. They're on this disastrous road trip to a most centric theme park. The wife and kids suggest that it's perhaps time to just go home. I don't want to be in the car anymore. I want to go home! Clark, under the circumstances,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。现在是夏天，所以我们觉得必须以一部经典的暑假电影里的场景来开始我们的节目。那是20世纪80年代，格里斯沃尔德一家挤在他们的旅行车里。下着倾盆大雨。一切都出了问题。他们正在进行一场通往某个全美瞩目主题公园的灾难性公路旅行。妻子和孩子们建议，也许是时候回家了。我再也不想坐车了。我想回家！克拉克，在这种情况下，
I wouldn't mind if we just went home. But the dad, Chevy Chase, has other ideas. We're 10 hours from the fun park and you want to bail out. Well, I'll tell you something, this is no longer a vacation. It's a quest. It's a quest for fun. I'm gonna have fun and you're gonna have fun. We're all gonna have so much f***ing fun when we need plastic surgery to remove our goddamn spiles. I gotta be crazy. I'm gonna pilgrimage to see a moose. Praise Marty Moose! Some vacations, we wait for them all year, we pour time, energy and money into planning them, expectations run unreasonably high, coming up a summer edition of Stopwatch Science,
我倒不介意我们就这样回家。但身为父亲的切维·蔡斯有别的想法。我们离游乐园还有10个小时的路程，而你想打退堂鼓。好吧，我告诉你，这已经不再是度假了。这是一次朝圣。是一场寻求快乐的朝圣。我会玩得开心，你们也会玩得开心。我们所有人都会玩得他妈的这么开心，以至于我们需要做整形手术来切除我们该死的微笑。我一定疯了。我要去朝圣看驼鹿。赞美马蒂驼鹿！有些假期，我们一年到头都在等待，我们把时间、精力和金钱投入到规划中，期望高得离谱，接下来是夏季版的“秒停科学”，
how to plan a vacation, what vacations can reveal about your stock portfolio, and why vacations can be bad for your waistline. If you're like me, Shankar, vacations bring to mind two words. Creeping obesity. Stay with us. Support for this podcast and the following message come from StitchFix, an online personal styling service that makes shopping effortless and fun for busy women on the go. Complete your personal style quiz and then schedule a date to receive
如何规划假期，假期能揭示关于你的股票投资组合的什么信息，以及为什么假期对你的腰围有害。如果你和我一样，尚卡尔，假期会让你联想到两个词。渐进性肥胖。请继续收听。本播客及以下信息的赞助商为 StitchFix，这是一家在线个人造型服务公司，让忙碌的女性在旅途中也能轻松有趣地购物。完成你的个人风格测验，然后预约时间接收
your first personalized shipment. There's no subscription required. Your stylist will send you five hand-selected pieces of clothing delivered right to your door. Buy what you want and send the rest back. Shipping is easy and free both ways. To get started, visit stitchfix.com. That's STI, TCH, f-i-x.com. Support also comes from outdoor voices. A new sportswear brand that takes a totally different approach to getting active.
你的第一笔个性化配送。无需订阅。你的造型师会为你挑选五件精选服装，直接送到你家门口。买你想要的，其余的退回。双向运费既简单又免费。要开始使用，请访问 stitchfix.com。即 STI, TCH, f-i-x.com。赞助还来自 Outdoor Voices。这是一个全新的运动服装品牌，采用完全不同的方法来激发活力。
Instead of harder, faster, stronger, they're all about embracing activity with ease, humor, and delight. Outdoor Voices delivers men's and women's technical athletic wear that's streamlined, comfortable, and made to last. And they're offering 15% off to our listeners. Just go to OutdoorVoices.com slash brain and enter coupon code brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I'm joined now by Daniel Pink. He's the author
比起更刻苦、更快、更强，他们更崇尚以轻松、幽默和愉悦的态度拥抱活动。Outdoor Voices 提供男士和女士功能性运动服，线条流畅、舒适且经久耐穿。他们为我们的听众提供 15% 的折扣。只需访问 OutdoorVoices.com/brain 并输入优惠券代码 brain。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。和我一起的是丹尼尔·平克。他是
of several books about human behavior, but on our show, as you know, his title is Senior Stop What Science correspondent. Welcome, Dan. Thank you, Shankar. It's great to be here. All right, so on Stop What Science, Dan and I give one another 60 seconds to summarize interesting social science research. As we approach the one-minute mark, our producers will bring up the music sometimes gently, sometimes loudly, to let us know our time is running out. Our topic today is vacations. This week we'll tell you why it's so important to take one and how to get the most out of your vacation. You know, Dan, whenever I'm with you, I actually feel like I'm on vacation.
几本关于人类行为的书的作者，但在我们的节目中，正如你所知，他的头衔是“秒停科学”资深通讯员。欢迎你，丹。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴来到这里。好的，在“秒停科学”中，丹和我给彼此60秒时间来总结有趣的社会科学研究。当我们接近一万字——哦不，一分钟大关时，我们的制作人会播放音乐，有时轻柔，有时响亮，让我们知道时间快到了。我们今天的主题是假期。本周我们将告诉你为什么度假如此重要，以及如何充分利用你的假期。你知道，丹，每当我和你在一起时，我真的觉得自己就像在度假。
Ah, that's why you're in a swimsuit? Exactly. Alrighty, alright, alright, alright, alright. Let's do some science. Alright, Dan, your first 60-second starts now. Shankar, everyone here at NPR headquarters knows that you're an upstanding citizen who never, ever would use his work computer for personal tasks. Did you? But some people aren't as scrupulous as you.
啊，这就是为什么你穿着泳衣？没错。好啦，好啦，好啦，好啦，好啦。让我们来做点科学研究。好的，丹，你的前60秒现在开始。尚卡尔，NPR总部的每个人都知道你是一个品行端正的公民，绝对、绝对不会在工作电脑上处理个人事务。你会吗？但有些人可没有你那么严谨。
And when it comes to vacation planning, that might be costing them. Way zhong of Iowa State University and Ajay Khaura of Rice University looked at a large trove of data from an online hotel reservation site. They found that people who booked leisure travel during work hours selected higher quality hotels than those who booked during travel during work hours selected higher quality hotels than those who booked during non-work hours. But once the vacation was over, those making reservations from the office ended up less satisfied with their hotel choice.
而在规划假期时，这可能会让他们付出代价。爱荷华州立大学的王扬（音译）和莱斯大学的阿贾伊·考拉查看了来自一个在线酒店预订网站的大量数据。他们发现，在工作时间内预订休闲旅游的人，比在非工作时间内预订的人选择了更高质量的酒店。但在假期结束时，那些从办公室进行预订的人对他们选择的酒店最终不太满意。
Now it's not clear exactly what's going on here, but one explanation seems plausible. When we're at work, we're more likely to be stressed out and depleted, and therefore less likely to be stressed out and depleted and therefore less likely to be vigilant. So instead of pushing hard to find a great deal, we settle for an OK deal that we later regret. Whatever the reason though, the message is clear, don't shop for travel at work. So let me understand this correctly.
现在还不清楚这具体是怎么回事，但有一个解释似乎是合理的。当我们在工作时，我们更有可能感到压力和精疲力竭，因此更不可能保持警惕。因此，与其努力寻找大优惠，我们不如凑合接受一个后来会后悔的普通优惠。不过无论出于什么原因，信息很明确：不要在工作时购买旅游产品。那么让我正确理解这一点。
They're saying that because people are stressed out and busy or maybe especially in need of a vacation when they're at work, they go online, they see something really snazzy, interesting, beautiful, and they say, yeah, I'm gonna buy that, but then when they actually go there, they find that if they had shopped around for another 10 minutes, they could have found something that was actually a better deal. Right, but we have only one deal here on stopwatch science, and that's a deal that involves 60 seconds seconds and those 60 seconds begin right now. Alright, when we think about great vacations, we often think about going to
他们是在说，因为人们在工作时感到压力大、很忙，或者可能特别需要假期，他们上网，看到一些非常时髦、有趣、美丽的东西，然后说，好吧，我要买那个，但当他们真正去到那里时，他们发现如果他们再货比三家10分钟，他们本可以找到一个其实更划算的选择。没错，但我们在“秒停科学”中只有一个选择，那就是涉及60秒的选择，而这60秒现在开始。好的，当我们想到精彩的假期时，我们经常想到去
unusual places, maybe going to a place that few other people have got, maybe you're already doing this, you're listening to this podcast right now on a beach in Tahiti. One advantage of unusual vacations is that we can then post pictures on Facebook or come home and tell our friends all about our amazing vacation. Now, since they haven't been to these wonderful locales, they will be eager listeners for our stories, right? So we think. No, they won't. Gus Cooney and Dan Gilbert at Harvard, along with Timothy Wilson at the University of Virginia, find that when people have amazingly unique experiences, they're often less happy afterward.
不寻常的地方，也许去一个很少其他人去过的地方，也许你已经在这么做了，你现在正躺在塔希提岛的海滩上听这个播客。不寻常假期的好处之一是，我们可以把照片发到Facebook上，或者回家把我们精彩的假期讲给朋友们听。现在，既然他们没有去过这些美妙的地方，他们就会渴望听我们的故事，对吧？我们是这么想的。不，他们才不。哈佛大学的格斯·库尼和丹·吉尔伯特，以及弗吉尼亚大学的蒂莫西·威尔逊发现，当人们拥有极其独特的体验时，他们事后往往不那么快乐。
Why? Your friends don't want to hear you drawn on about getting on that SpaceX flight. They are talking to each other about the block party in the neighborhood that you missed, so you feel socially isolated, social isolation matters more to your happiness than your vacation destination.
为什么？你的朋友们才不想听你唠叨你坐上了那趟SpaceX的航班。他们正在互相讨论你错过的社区街区派对，所以你会感到被社会孤立，社会孤立对你快乐的影响比你的度假目的地更重要。
This is very interesting, so how do they do this? Did they send one group of people to the Caribbean and another group to the banks of the Ollentangie River in Central Ohio? They both sound pretty exotic to me then, but no, that's not what they did. This was a social psychology experiment, which means it was done on the cheap. What they did is they brought and volunteers into a laboratory and they sat the majority of them down together to watch a very mediocre movie and they sat one person down to watch an absolutely fantastic riveting movie and then they put the whole group together to talk and the person who'd watch the amazing movie wanted to talk about the amazing movie
这非常有趣，那么他们是怎么做到的呢？他们是把一组人送到加勒比海，把另一组人送到俄亥俄州中部的奥伦坦吉河畔吗？对我来说，这两个听起来都挺异国情调的，丹，但不是，他们不是这么做的。这是一项社会心理实验，这意味着它是廉价完成的。他们的做法是把志愿者带进实验室，让他们中的大多数人坐在一起看一部非常平庸的电影，而让一个人坐下来看一部绝对精彩、引人入胜的电影，然后把整个小组聚在一起聊天，看过那部精彩电影的人想谈论那部精彩的电影
that he or she had watched but of course none of the others had seen the amazing movie and they didn't really want to talk about it they wanted to talk about what a silly experiment this was the others bonded with each other and the person who watched the great movie ended up feeling isolated. I see. And so how does this play into this idea that experiences are more valuable to us than goods? That's interesting because there is a lot of research showing that experiences are more valuable than things when you're buying yourself gifts, but I've actually come by recent work then that actually finds that the reason experiences are often better than things as gifts is that experiences are inherently often social.
他或她看过的电影，但当然其他人都没有看过那部精彩的电影，他们其实并不想谈论它，他们想谈论这是一个多么愚蠢的实验。其他人彼此建立了联系，而看那部好电影的人最终感到被孤立。我明白了。那么这与“体验比物品对我们更有价值”这个观点是如何契合的呢？这很有趣，因为有很多研究表明，当你给自己买礼物时，体验比物品更有价值，但我最近的一项研究发现，体验之所以通常比物品更适合作为礼物，其实是因为体验往往本质上具有社交性。
If you're going on an experience and actually enjoying it entirely by yourself, it's not clear that it actually is much better than just buying yourself a new television set or a new car. It's the social aspect of experiences that makes them better. This is why when I do stop watch science by myself at home, it's no fun. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha words. Creeping obesity. That's the medical concept for what happens to many of us in middle age. We don't become overweight overnight. Instead, we gain a pound or two each year. And before long, that person in the mirror looks a little different. Well, according to a recent paper in the journal physiology and behavior, our vacations could be part of the problem. These researchers studied 122 adults who'd gone on vacations of between 1 and 3 weeks.
如果你去体验并且完全是自己一个人在享受它，那它其实并不比给自己买一台新电视或一辆新车好多少。正是体验的社交方面让它们变得更好。这就是为什么当我独自在家做“秒停科学”时，一点意思也没有。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
They find that these folks each gain nearly a pound on vacation, and that the extra weight was still there six weeks later. Now the reason is intriguing. Turns out people are more physically active on vacation, so inactivity wasn't the cause. The real culprit was that vacationers increased their calorie consumption in excess of their activity, especially in the form of alcohol. Oh, yeah, of course. So if you want to avoid weight gain while on holiday, try to drink less. Although that might be tough if you're on a family vacation
研究人员研究了 122 名度假 1 到 3 周的成年人。他们发现这些人每个人在度假期间都增重了近一磅，而且六周后多出来的体重依然还在。原因很耐人寻味。原来人们在度假时身体活动更多，所以缺乏活动并不是原因。真正的罪魁祸首是度假者增加了超过其活动量的卡路里消耗，尤其是以酒精的形式。哦，是的，当然。所以如果你想在度假时避免增重，试着少喝点酒。尽管如果你在进行家庭度假，这可能会很艰难。
So this makes total sense to me then I often feel that I'm significantly more active when I'm on vacations But I have noticed that I don't lose weight while I'm on vacations and it's probably because I'm just eating and drinking more Right and especially the drinking part this this paper showed something like a doubling in alcohol consumption during the weeks that people are away. So they're living it up, but they're paying for it later in creeping obesity. So speaking of creeping, your moment has crept to us right now in your 60 seconds begins right now. All right, vacations can be fun, they can be relaxing, but they can also be very useful signals. Think about your own behavior. If you're the boss of a company and your own vacation is your company likely to make big moves that rock the boat, not likely, or let's say you're the boss and things are falling apart at work.
所以这对我完全说得通，丹，我经常觉得我在度假时明显更活跃。但我注意到我在度假时并没有减肥，这可能只是因为我吃得更多、喝得更多。没错，尤其是喝酒这部分，这篇论文显示，人们离开的几周内，酒精消耗量大约翻了一番。所以他们过得很潇洒，但他们后来要为渐进性肥胖付出代价。说到渐进，你的时间刚刚不知不觉来到了我们这里，你的60秒现在开始。好吧，度假可以很有趣，可以让人放松，但它们也可以是非常有用的信号。想想你自己的行为。如果你是一家公司的老板，你自己的假期会不会让你的公司做出打破常规的大动作？不太可能，或者假设你是老板，工作正一团糟。
Now, you might have to cancel your vacation to deal with the crisis. In other words, paying attention to when the boss goes on vacation can be a market signal. Interesting. David Yormack at NYU tracked when CEOs go on vacation by merging records of corporate jetflights and where CEOs of various companies are known to have vacation properties. He finds that CEOs are more likely to go on vacation right after their company's announced good news.
现在，你可能不得不取消假期去处理危机。换句话说，关注老板什么时候去度假可以成为一个市场信号。有趣的是，纽约大学的大卫·约马克（David Yormack）通过合并公司喷气式飞机飞行的记录以及已知各公司CEO拥有度假房产的地方，追踪了CEO们何时去度假。他发现，CEO们更有可能在公司宣布好消息后立即去度假。
And he also finds that stock prices for a company are less volatile when the CEO is on break. In other words, if you and I were running a hedge fund then we might want to keep better track of which CEOs are hitting the beach this summer and which ones are canceling their travel plans. Yeah, this is a great study. This is really interesting.
他还发现，当CEO在度假时，公司股价波动较小。换句话说，如果你和我当时在经营一家对冲基金，我们可能会想更好地追踪哪些CEO今年夏天去了海滩，哪些人取消了他们的旅行计划。是的，这是一项很棒的研究。这真的很有趣。
So do you think that investors, funds are actually using this kind of information to make bets on companies? I think they might be, except it probably isn't easy to come by all the information that David Yormac pulled together. It's also probably the case that the signal is a small signal. So the only way to really be successful at this is if you apply the strategy over a very, very lengthy period of time, and in the long run, the law of averages will work in your favor. Now, the law of averages don't necessarily work on your favor in stopwatch science because
所以你认为投资者、基金真的在使用这类信息来押注公司吗？我想他们可能会，除了大卫·约马克汇集的所有信息可能不容易获得之外。情况也可能是这个信号很小。所以真正能够成功的唯一方法是将该策略应用于非常非常长的时间段，从长远来看，平均法则会为你工作。现在，平均法则在秒停科学中不一定对你有利，因为
we have only 60 seconds to pull things off, and your next 60 seconds Dan starts right now. Vacations can recharge the mind and replenish the soul, but once we're back on the job, how long do the positive effects last? Two German psychologists tackled that question in the Journal of Organizational Behavior. The researchers chose a profession with lots of stress and high burnout rates. Teachers. They had teachers fill out questionnaires the day before a two-eification, and then three more times after the vacation had ended, and they were back on the job.
我们只有60秒来完成任务，而你的下一个60秒，丹，现在开始。假期可以重塑心灵并补充灵魂，但一旦我们回到工作岗位，积极的效果能持续多久？两位德国心理学家在《组织行为学杂志》上探讨了这个问题。研究人员选择了一个压力大、倦怠率高的职业：教师。他们让教师在两周假期前的前一天以及假期结束回到工作岗位后填写了三次问卷。
First, the good news. When the teachers returned to the classroom after their ended and they were back on the job. First the good news, when the teachers returned to the classroom after their break, they were more engaged in their jobs and significantly less emotionally exhausted. The vacation worked. Now the less good news, that positive boost faded away after only about four weeks. A month after returning to work, they were generally back to their provocation levels of engagement and exhaustion. Now, we can't leap to universal conclusions here.
首先，好消息。当老师们休假结束后回到教室时，他们对工作的投入度更高，情绪上的精疲力竭也明显减少。假期起作用了。现在是不太好的消息，这种积极的提振在大约四周后就消退了。回到工作一个月后，他们的投入度和精疲力竭程度大体上回到了他们挑衅前——哦不，他们原本的水平。现在，我们不能在这里得出普遍的结论。
Maybe there's something unique about teachers or Germans, but if the benefits of time off do fade out so quickly, perhaps we should all be taking more vacations. There's something terribly sad about that story, Dan, because it really suggests that we have these dreams about what vacations will do, and even when those dreams come true, what you're saying is that the effects are likely to be very short-lived. That's what it seems like, and you know what we've seen that before in other areas. If you look at, wait, generally people return to what's called their set point of weight.
也许教师或德国人有什么独特之处，但如果休假的好处消退得如此之快，也许我们都应该休更多假。那个故事里有一些非常悲伤的东西，丹，因为它真的表明我们对假期会有什么作用抱有梦想，甚至当这些梦想成真时，你所说的是这些效果很可能是短暂的。看起来确实如此，你知道我们在其他领域也见过这种情况。如果你看看，体重通常人们会回到所谓的设定点。
You know, they might lose some here, gain some here, but in general, they return to that set point. Even if you look at this measure of subjective well-being, how happy we are, you know what? Something really bad happens to you. It drops. Something really great happens to you. It goes up. But then it returns to that same level. Which sort of leads to the question of actually, what's the point of taking a vacation at all?
你知道，他们可能会在这里减掉一些，在这里增加一些，但总的来说，他们会回到那个设定点。即使你看看主观幸福感的这个指标，我们有多快乐，你知道吗？发生了一件非常糟糕的事。它下降了。发生了一件非常棒的事。它上升了。但随后它又回到了同一水平。这有点引出了一个问题，实际上，休假到底有什么意义？
If you're going to come back to who you are at the end of it Maybe you should just stay home Maybe you should just stay at work and just keep working and working and working until you grind yourself into full despair And don't even hit your set point. That's a great suggestion. I'm sure our listeners would love it I'm hoping that your next one is a little bit more uplifting Shankar your 60 seconds start right now. All right, we did a podcast episode recently about Alaska looking at climate change.
如果你在结束时还是要回到原来的自己，也许你该待在家里。也许你该待在工作岗位上，一直工作、工作、工作，直到把你磨成彻底的绝望，甚至连你的设定点都达不到。这是一个很好的建议。我确信我们的听众会喜欢它。我希望你的下一个建议能稍微振奋人心一点。尚卡尔，你的60秒现在开始。好的，我们最近做了一期关于阿拉斯加气候变化的播客节目。
I went there on vacation with my family recently. And when you're in Alaska Dan with all those mountains and glaciers and vast open spaces, you can't help but notice that you're a very, very small animal on a very, very big planet. Now we've all felt this. You've looked up at the sky in a dark night. You've seen the Milky Way,
我最近和家人去那里度假了。当你在阿拉斯加时，丹，面对所有的山脉、冰川和广阔的开放空间，你禁不住会注意到自己是一个生活在一个非常巨大的星球上的非常非常小的动物。现在我们都曾感受到这一点。你曾在黑夜里仰望天空。你见过银河，
where you listen to a beautiful piece of music, you feel a sense of majesty, a sense of awe. Paul Piff, Docker-Caltoner, and many other researchers, have found that awe not only does wonderful things for you, but that it helps you do wonderful things for others. Volunteers induce to feel awe, act more altruistically, more ethically. They stop thinking of themselves and their problems as bigger or more important than
或者你听到一首优美的音乐，你感受到一种宏伟感，一种敬畏感。保罗·皮夫、道格·卡尔托纳以及许多其他研究人员发现，敬畏不仅对你大有裨益，还能帮助你为他人做伟大的事情。被诱发产生敬畏感的志愿者表现得更加利他、更加合乎道德。他们不再认为自己和他们的问题比
others. So, if you're in vacation right now, whether that's a hike around the neighborhood or a hike around the Grand Canyon, remember that one of the most important things you can do is to let yourself get caught up in the moment. Feel grateful, feel awe. It's one of the ways vacations can make us better people. Interesting. So if you're at that black party rather than the SpaceX flight,
其他人更宏大或更重要。所以，如果你现在正在度假，无论是在社区里徒步还是在大峡谷徒步，记住你能做的最重要的事情之一就是让自己沉浸在当下。心存感激，感受敬畏。这是假期能让我们成为更好的人的方式之一。有趣的是。所以如果你在那个黑基派对上而不是SpaceX航班上，
look up in the air, wave to the other guy who's miserable in that SpaceX flight, and look at the clouds and just sort of get a sense of awe with your friends and your family. Yeah, I think so, this is the thing. I think many of us believe that the source of awe is in the things that we're seeing and the things that we're noticing. But in many ways, I think the source of the awe is in ourselves.
抬头看看天空，向那个在SpaceX航班上苦恼的家伙挥挥手，看看云彩，和你的朋友家人一起感受一种敬畏感。是的，我想是的，就是这样。我想我们很多人都认为敬畏的源泉在于我们看到的东西和我们注意到的事情。但在很多方面，我认为敬畏的源泉在于我们自己。
It's in our ability, our orientation to actually look at the world and appreciate how marvelous it is. Yeah, also based on that study, I really think that there's a lesson for the Alaska Department of Tourism. There should have a campaign that says, welcome to Alaska. That's yours, folks in Juneau for the taking. So there's some marketing advice from Dan Pink, and there you have it, book your next vacation at home, pick the neighborhood block party over the SpaceX flight,
它在于我们的能力，我们审视世界并欣赏它是多么奇妙的方向感。是的，也根据那项研究，我真的认为这对阿拉斯加旅游局是一个教训。他们应该发起一个活动，上面写着：欢迎来到阿拉斯加。朱诺的朋友们，那是留给你们的。这里有来自丹·平克的营销建议，就是这样，把你的下一次假期定在家里，选择社区街区派对而不是SpaceX航班，
drink less while you're on vacation, try to keep that vacation bliss going a little longer after you get back, perhaps by soaking up lots of awe-inspiring moments. Finally, if any of you see Dan Pink hastily cancelled his vacation plans in the last minute, you can be fairly confident that the hidden brain hedge fund that we run together is about to tank. Dan, thank you for joining me.
在度假时少喝点酒，试着让这种度假的幸福感在你回去后多持续一会儿，也许通过沉浸在许多令人敬畏的时刻中。最后，如果你们任何人看到丹·平克在最后一分钟匆忙取消了他的度假计划，你可以相当自信地认为我们一起经营的那个隐藏的大脑对冲基金快要崩盘了。丹，谢谢你加入我。
It's always a pleasure. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Max Nestrak and Chris Benderev, and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our staff also includes Maggie Pennman and Karamagar Galison. We should also say it's Max's last week with us at Hidden Brain before he moves on to a new job in public radio. Many of you loved our recent episode featuring Max's last week with us at Hidden Brain before he moves on to a new job in public radio. Many of you loved our recent episode featuring Max's effort to quit smoking. He's promised to keep us posted on how that goes. We're going to miss you, Max. You can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen to my stories on your local public radio station.
这始终是一种荣幸。本期《隐藏的大脑》由马克斯·内斯特拉克（Max Nestrak）和克里斯·本德列夫（Chris Benderev）制作，珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）编辑。我们的员工还包括玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Pennman）和卡拉马加·加利森（Karamagar Galison）。我们还应该说，这是马克斯在我们这里的最后一周，之后他将前往公共广播开启新工作。你们许多人喜欢我们最近播出一集关于马克斯戒烟努力的节目。他答应随时向我们通报进展情况。我们会想念你的，马克斯。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。
If you like this episode, give us a review. It helps. I'm Shankar Vedant, and this is NPR. Hey y'all, Sam Sanders here, Campaign Reporter with NPR News. Here to tell you that the NPR Politics Podcast has you covered for the biggest two weeks of this election year so far. Skip the cable news, hang over, and listen to our daily episodes from the Republican and Democratic conventions in Cleveland and Philadelphia. Every day about conventions, it all starts July 19th.
如果你喜欢这一集，请给我们写个评价。这很有帮助。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。大家好，我是山姆·桑德斯（Sam Sanders），NPR新闻的竞选记者。来告诉大家，NPR政治播客已经为您报道了今年迄今为止这次选举中最关键的两周。抛开有线电视新闻的宿醉，收听我们从克里夫兰和费城的共和党及民主党全国代表大会发回的每日节目。每天都有关于大会的报道，7月19日全面开启。
Subscribe to the NPR Politics Podcast at npr.org slash podcast or on the NPR One app. Thanks. podcast or on the NPR1 app. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 npr.org/podcast 或 NPR One 应用上订阅 NPR 政治播客。谢谢。播客或在 NPR One 应用上。谢谢。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。